let's go next to our caller from the
nine zero one area code who's calling
today from nine zero one
my name is Brandon and I'm from Memphis
hey Brandon what's going on um nothing
much I'm I'm really happy to be that you
took my call thank you so much
I am well first of all I just wanted to
say that I really appreciate what you do
and being someone who is in in Memphis
Tennessee it's it's really nice that you
know I get to enjoy a rational
perspective thank one on youtube in the
environment that I'm on um you and
calloc Olinsky and Bo of the fifth
column are kind of my guys but uh I'm
sorry anyway under my question do you
think censorship of teachers is a
problem well you both so I mean you
depending on what you're referring to
the answer will vary it what exactly do
you mean what kind of censorship and of
which teachers well it's it's actually
not really it's actually not really
censorship I guess that's the wrong word
right I mean what I guess work more so
what I mean is suppression because
there's there's a like a really heavy
societal stigma against teachers being
politically active right and I know a
lot of teachers and a lot of them are
afraid to say things certain things
online because they're afraid of you
know getting fired and things like that
so there's a couple different things
going on here there's the idea of
teachers being forced not to be
political in the classroom or if they're
going to be political it has to be for
one side or the other depending on the
whims of the school district and then
there's the issue of teachers being
activists outside of of the classroom
I'm not aware I let me put it a
different way I know many teachers in
different parts of the country mmm
who are activists and they go to climate
rallies and they go to whatever it is
and it has never caused an issue in the
classroom because they're not talking
about that stuff in the classroom so so
that's that's number one are you talking
about teachers that are like fired
because they did something outside of
work well it's it's it's a fear of that
it's the fear that if I go on social
media and say or protest or if I go out
in the streets and do something yeah
that I mean there's going to be
repercussions on me in my workplace and
that's why a lot of the teachers that I
know completely avoid the subject which
I thought was funny considering a large
the large the largest percentage of
Bernie supporters I think was reported
that they were teachers they're choosing
to not be activists because they're
afraid of being fired then that's a
problem and I think that they should be
able to do whatever activism they want
to do outside of the classroom you know
where it starts to get dicey would be
hypothetically if they're advocating for
something you know that would be
problematic in the way it would relate
to being around kids but I don't know
that I necessarily need to steal man
that I mean those cases are extremely
few and far between I think the more
interesting discussion quite frankly
Brandon is the one about in the
classroom because there's this idea of
teachers shouldn't be political in the
classroom and I've talked about this
before in college I have no problem with
teachers being more political in the
classroom if the subject matter in
relates to politics and in many ways it
does if you're in a calculus 2 class it
doesn't seem like there's really a place
for politics but if you're teaching
sociology or communication or whatever
the case may be
it's unreasonable to imagine that being
extricated from the political world and
I'm okay
with political biases coming out in the
classroom from teachers as long as
they're identified as such and no one's
voice is being suppressed or whatever
the case may be in elementary school in
high school it's a different situation
and I think particularly in classes that
don't relate to politics I can
understand why parents would prefer that
politics not be a part of the curriculum
and I don't know many people who argue
against that quite
frankly yeah it's just something I
wanted to ask about it's something I've
experienced with a lot of teachers that
you know I want them to speak their
minds I want them to put their opinions
out there but they don't want to because
they're they're scared of you know
yeah well listen if you're if you're
just showing up at a protest and and
holding a sign that is constitutionally
protected and teachers should not be
afraid of that and if they are we've got
to deal with that Brandon thank you for
the call I appreciate hearing from you
very very much hope to hear from you
again